presenting
experimentation on network specifically
you have 45 minutes
thank you very much so this is about
Innovation and its diffusion so here's
one Innovation was an innovation five
years ago and it was so successful in
Santa Monica that they introduced it
here and there and there and there and
then it was everywhere on the world
right so some Innovations take off
others don't right so
um the paper is not about scooters of
course it's about Innovation it's
diffusion more General
and uh you know it's the first order
economic question right so mukher argues
that uh Innovation and its diffusion are
both necessary and hence complementary
for sustained economic growth
right so from a production perspective
they're complementary from a strategic
perspective they're substitutable right
so uh Grossman and stiglas in their
famous Paradox argue that if all
information is relevant in financial
markets can be gleaned for market prices
who would generate this information in
the first place right it's on
centralized markets we have a good
understanding of that right there's
auction Theory there's financial markets
Theory we understand how this sort of
pans out in equilibrium and we're trying
to do in this paper here is to develop a
theory of how how this
substitution how this crowding out of
private experimentation from social
learning how this pans out in a
decentralized uh network setting right
so I'm not going to take a stance on the
specific application certainly not
scooters
um so what I have in mind are the
classical the classical papers on uh on
learning on networks right so acrylic is
a corn farmers in Iowa or Coleman's
doctors who learn from their social
contacts about this new thing out there
so the questions I want to address as to
I want to quantify this crowding out
right how is it that social information
crowds out the individual incentives to
generate the information in the first
place how does this depend on the
network and the position of the
individuals within the network and I'm
going to talk also about the classical
question of social learning as this
economy grows large as there is sort of
sufficient there's a potential physical
for perfect learning will it happen in
equilibrium
foreign
so the model is going to be very simple
on the learning side right so
experimentation is going to be good old
perfect good news learning right that's
going to buy a lot of traction here it's
going to allow us to allow for a lot of
richness on the on the network side
right so networks are coming fairly
General and still will get not quite
unique but unique learning Dynamics like
in terms of the results the two big
results in the paper are going to be
well how does Network density the number
of links in the network to connect this
how does it affect the the information
that's being generated and then
importantly the welfare all right so one
shortcoming of course of the social
learning literature is that it has
focused very much on Long on Long Run
outcomes and we know in the long run
we're all that right so welfare of
course takes sort of a shorter medium
term perspective
and the tractability of the model is
going to allow us to talk also to
welfare right so information
unsurprising is when we're decreasing a
density as we can learn more as there's
more social information individuals will
generate less information right so
aggregate information in the long term
is going to decrease as a network cross
dancer
but welfare is going to be hump shaped
right so maybe not so surprising because
for welfare a density is also a good
thing right because a dental network is
the faster I'm going to learn if I'm
impatient that's a good thing
right so that's the main result so
Network density is bad for information
in the long run it has a hump shaped
effect on on welfare
and then there's going to be other
results that I may or may not get to
talking about sort of the the effect of
position within the network and the
types of links that connect the network
right so here's a here's sort of a
Mickey Mouse version of the model so the
kind of behavior that's going to happen
in equilibrium and so here this is my
favorite network the star Network
and so initially everybody's going to
experiment because this new thing has
Prospect and the colors don't work out
well here so this would be gray dots on
my computer and this is a white dot here
right so the the peripherals are
experimenting the center he's getting so
much Social information the center is is
not experimenting centers waiting and
seeing and eventually somebody succeeds
because you know uh Randomness right and
so then
um at this point here you can't see it
because of the colors I apologize the
peripheral guys get pessimistic because
they have experimented for a while they
haven't seen a success they give up on
this Innovation whereas these guys here
they have succeeded in the center guy
he's seen this year succeed so the
center guy knows this is actually
valuable the center guy keeps
experimenting and at this point the
model becomes a standard SI diffusion
process right so these guys you would
call them infected or call this guy
infected and it's going to spread the
Innovation through the network but it's
going to take time right and so
eventually everybody is going to be
going to be affected here right and so
coming back to the question from the
last slide about Network density what
happens if I add a second Central node
right what if the star has a core of two
and you might say other people it's
going to be great because it's going to
accelerate the fusion and yes it does
right but you know if there's the few if
the diffusion is faster
then of course the incentives of the
peripherals to generate the information
in the first place that has gone to
decrease and so that's the trade-off
that the paper sticker
all right so here's the literature
um there's been there's literature on
strategic experimentation on The Clique
and you may wonder which of these models
are we putting on network here not quite
any one of them right so we're
subtly but importantly different from
these uh from these papers
uh in terms of the network literature
what this paper is trying to do is to be
the equilibrium version of the seminal
paper babala and goyal but the Bala
goyal is not an experimentation paper
right it's a paper we're learning on
networks but the agents are myopic right
so they don't purposefully experiment
they just sort of act on the information
they've received in the past whereas our
agents are forward-looking what happened
to Paula goyal and they introduction and
say you know it'd be nice to talk about
forward-looking agents which is too
complicated because of the network right
and so how do we do it well we have a
simpler information structure than them
right also the agents in palogial
they're not just myopic but they're also
not fully Bayesian because
the assumption is that in Bala goyal
that you only observe others
no You observe others actions and their
outcomes
um and of course when you see their
actions their actions that you make an
inference about what your neighbors have
seen but you yourself have not seen
right so that's like in the classical
big chandani hush like a world social
learning model
and they just shut down that model they
shut down the channel they say yes You
observe other actions but you fail to
draw an inference from that right you
see others taking their actions and see
their outcomes you interpret as an
experiment and interpret the outcomes of
the experiment rationally
but you're not drawing any inference
from their actions
so in that sense they're not fully
Bayesian and the way we get around that
is by just saying that our agents are
not going to observe the actions of the
others
so that might in principle raise other
problems but with the with the simple
learning process that we have we can we
can address this
let me give you the model and then I'm
going to pause
here's the here's the model to the
network is is General
and so capital G would be a random
Network
lowercase G would be the deterministic
network
most of the applications are going to be
domestic networks sometimes the the
networks are going to be random
the learning game is as simple as they
get right so every agent is doing their
their experimentation right so
um the actions they are they're private
and the payoffs are private right so if
my action has a cost of C to me taking
this in continuous time
and if the state is high right so this
is the key assumption here that's a
perfect good news learning assumption if
the state is high I may succeed at these
times here and then I but only I get the
uh get the payoff from this right so
there's no pair of externalities right
so when I
I have a corn farmer try this new hybrid
corn I may get a pump bumper bumper
Harvest that doesn't affect your payoffs
right so the only channel of interaction
is informational right I see I see my
successes I see my neighbor's successes
in this network
and uh from that I draw my inferences
but there's no pay effects analogies
did you summarize okay and the state is
either lower high end there's a belief
about that initially it's a common prior
P0 and to summarize here the the the
problem that every agent solves here
agent I
is a full in general it's a
fantastic dynamical control problem and
choosing this Control process here right
so at this level might be very
complicated to maximumize my payoffs
which are the payoffs from my successes
at these times here minus the cost of
the experimentation
and it's going to simplify significantly
on the next two slides yeah
different
ly like I see if you're experimenting
but not
no it's not very wrong I see your
successes not their experimentation
okay so my Farmers they don't see what
seeds their uh their neighbors are
planting but they see when the neighbor
starts driving around for the new Tesla
if there's how do you observe your
neighbor's successes
are
um
okay so in the in the main case of
deterministic networks I know who my
neighbors are right in random networks
I'm uh I'm literally saying I don't know
what the realization network is we could
change that as we could add that we're
not using that so that's what I'm
putting in the model
but
um you know who are my neighbors who are
my friends who are the people who might
succeed
I know how many friends do I have I
don't know
right so that's the perspective there
and you know I mean different
applications that might be more or less
realistic and doesn't really matter I'm
just not going to make use of that
information so I'm not putting that in
here
and so I'm only having two polar extreme
cases where I either know the entire
network before I know nothing about the
network and you know there's plenty of
sort of in between cases with asymmetric
information the most natural one of
course would be where I know who my
neighbors
an expectation is over my belief it
changes over time based on the
observation
yeah that expectation is a beast right
so it's about everything right it's
about the network it's about
um everybody's successes and their
successes are gonna affect my actions
and you know at this point this this is
enormous thing right I mean yeah the
network and all the realizations
yeah but it's going to go away in a
slightly
simplification here is
not seeing what my neighbor chose allows
simplify space
heard that if I saw them
The Continuous time it wouldn't even be
clear what a strategy is if I observed
my neighbor's actions because I see
their action and then immediately I
might want to react to that and to run
into these measurability issues okay so
if the actions were observable I would
set this up in discrete time
uh but but it would still substantially
still be very difficult because you know
let's say that sort of my second
neighbor succeeds and my first neighbor
starts taking the high action and then I
would start acting on that
um but then of course my my first
neighbor might have a signaling
incentive it would get very messy right
so making the making the efforts private
um it's clearly attractable of the
Assumption and you know in in
applications it's you know in some
applications more reasonable than others
left so
and so and so I skipped the empirical
papers but there are papers on uh on
fracking and for social learning by
trackers and social learning by all
extractors and when they say well do I
know what my neighbor on the neighboring
fact is doing uh they they say well you
could kind of learn it but it'd be
really difficult and you'd have to go to
this archives and sort of try to
decipher this information and you know
maybe at some point you're going to
learn it but then the model is a little
and so I'm taking the same assumption
that the emperor
uh they start a poisson process of
successes yes and what's r
with I are
letter r or the Reit respect okay
all right so I mean uh planning goes
into the Hat bunny comes out of the Hat
if I see a success I know what the state
is because the low State never never
leads to successes right so once I see
the first success game is essentially
over
I know the state is high and since I
assume that X is greater than C I'll
take the high action forever after right
so if either I succeed at time t or one
of my neighbors succeeds I'm done
right so the game really only happens
for me before that first time right so
we can focus everything on the time
before my first observed success which
in general in a general network is going
to be person specific
um uh here why why is going to be my
continuation value of taking the high
action forever after when I know the
state is high right so I'm going to
truncate the game usually in my pair of
Expressions at that time
and then we would call my own action
before learning the first success I'm
going to call this lower a t naught for
not having observed a success
and you know the important thing of
course the social learning and what I
get from others that is going to be the
BT right so my expectation over my
neighbor's actions conditional on uh on
me not having succeeded and my neighbors
not having succeeded yet I'm going to
call that thing here my social learning
curve that's the rate at which
information hits me and it makes sense
to condition on the highest state
because on a low State no successes ever
occur anyway right so that is the that
is sort of reasonable that's a
reasonable measure of of social learning
and it's going to be capital b in a
second that is going to be the integral
of lowercase b right so that's the rate
of social learning and then it's going
to be cumulative social learning and
this expectation is also respect of it
yes
yeah so if the network is unknown
and I wonder are there any friends out
there
I don't see successes I get pessimistic
both about the state and about my social
status
right okay so uh base rule right so if I
don't see a success I get more
pessimistic right so that's the
aggregate learning that has happened
before time T when I stick that into
into base rule here and that gives me my
posterior right so I start at P0 and
then I get more and more pessimistic as
as all our experimentation fails to
succeed
and uh the the stochastic control
problem has now become a bituministic
control problem because I'm truncating
everything at the first success right so
what's in the integrand now here at time
T
um I'm experimenting well if I'm
experimenting
um I may get the success myself
I make it a success that gives me X it
also gives me the continuation value of
y if others succeed I well I don't get
to pay off directly there's no X here
but I can take the high action forever
after so I do get the the continuation
value right so now I have to Discount
the future not just at the at my
impatience rate but also at the rate
that we are observing successes because
that that gives me my continuation value
so I'm I've put sort of the the
continuation value and the integrand and
so I have to correct for that in the in
the discontent
so this this is sort of Step number one
I never really understood that it's like
the third time but what is it what is
happening in this compactor is that the
time if I could I guess you're is that
the time is that why it's in the
exponent or
um
so mathematics is integration by parts
okay so you're doing I guess you're
doing an integration by part step there
that's not supposed to be entirely
transparent no no mathematically it's
not transparent I think economic is
intuitive right that uh if I say that at
some time when success arrives I I
collect my combination value why I'm
putting that into the integrand and you
know effectively that's that's
truncating the
the the expression here my future
payoffs at that time right and so you
can think of R of course you can think
of R balls as the interest rate or at my
death rate where you know I die and I
don't get future payoffs but you know
then this is sort of the rate at which I
die and that's the way at which I learn
and get my why
and so that that's how it makes sense
that it appears here together with r
because it is the same serrated with the
problem is
all right so I transformed a
stochastical control problem into the
domestic control problem it's through
that right by Imagine Learning here's
step number two to solve this the
diminished control problem I choose a
cutoff right so the optimal response no
matter what others are doing is to
choose a Time 17 in a Time 17 if I
hadn't observed the success I'm going to
stop experimenting as I stop
experimenting there's of course
conditional not having observed success
and that I don't stop forever I sit
there I wait and see and if somebody
else succeeds then of course I jump back
in and I start again I'm going to say
stopping time Tau it's conditional on
not having observed success
right uh so why is a cut-off strategy
optimal you know why would it not be
optimal right I'm getting more
pessimistic over time I'm failing
everybody else is failing I'm getting
more pessimistic why would I sort of
experiment not experiment now then later
when I've gotten bad information why
would I start later that's essentially
the proof right so if you write the
proof If you think of front loading a
little bit of experimentation right so
if I think well maybe I should sort of
wait a bit and then experiment later if
I take that little bit of
experimentation from later and Pull It
Forward
that's going to be that's going to be
beneficial for me how is this uh
Incorporated week a weight strategy like
in the start what
after I've stopped and I don't restart
unless I see something I only the wait
and see strategy wait and see
interpretation of the strategy is that
I'm waiting for success and after our
sex success I start and so what this is
saying is I I would never restart if I
don't see success
only there's good news so this doesn't
fully characterize my strategy then
because you don't know if I'm either
waiting or
or experimenting at times less than Tau
basically categorizes my strategy so I
don't understand the strategy I'm just
saying if I don't I'm going to
experiment I'm going to take the high
action until time tell no matter what
after times how I'm only going to
experiment if I've seen a success
learning to experiment organic
real world applications
very good that's what they do they're
adopting main issue you know planting
these seeds uh as a farmer and then they
they only pay off at random times if you
don't get the payoff right away you're
getting them with this croissant delay
but then what is this
previous language right I mean it's just
really just a high action below actually
and I'm calling it experimentation when
you're doing it while you're uncertain
after you're uncertain you know you can
still call experimentation but
in a way
sorry just declare so the strategy is
you win you try it for Cal steps and
then if if you haven't succeeded then
you stop and then if you see a success
then you restart experimentation and you
never stop until you succeed or
confusing when you succeed
forever yeah
yeah did you know there would be an
isomorphic model where you only succeed
once and so you know you'd have to sort
of re renormalize payoffs but that would
be the same model
right
um
okay so titles are optimal then of
course very important right because I
started with sort of a complicated
stochastic control problem and now I'm
saying you're just choosing a cutoff
right so what's the first order
condition for the cutoff right if I
increase the cutoff a little bit right
so this is my payoff here this is my
strategy that's my social learning curve
that comes from others if I raise my
cutoff a little bit what's the payoff
from that
um you know uh with probably petao at
times how the state is still high right
so that's my posterior belief
if I uh if I experiment I may succeed
that's getting me the X here and I
shouldn't have shown you this uh let me
give you a simpler version of this let's
assume that the social learning curve B
is constant that I'm getting the
information from the others at a
constant rate
so then the net benefit of experimenting
would be
would be a pitau times x
X Plus y right so the experiment I'm
getting my payoff X and I'm getting the
continuation value y there's a cost of
experimenting C of course and then
there's an opportunity cost of uh of not
learning from others right when I learn
myself I'm not benefiting from their
information anymore if they're
experimenting at a constant rate B my
value from learning from them would be
um P Tau times B divided by B plus r
right so if I'm learning a constant rate
from the others the value of that is
going to be discounted because you know
I'm going to only going to learn from
them in the future and uh and you know a
little bit of algebra shows you that b
divided by B plus r is the right is the
right expression and pulling that in
here then it becomes r divided by R plus
b times times Y and you know now more
generally if the if the B function is
not constant right in general it's not
going to be you know then it's going to
show up in the in the exponent here
like
the x is the payoff that I'm directly
getting when I succeed and why is the
continuation value from taking the high
action Forever After in the high state
details the posterior belief that the
state is high
what we see here already is that
this formalizes the crowding out idea
right if there's high social learning if
I'm getting a lot of information from
others you know the exponent is going to
be large the integral is going to be
small and the benefits from
experimenting on this small
B is equal to zero if there's no
information from others solving the
single agent problem and then I'm
experiment experimenting for a long time
in belief space What uh how does the
optimal strategy look like
well if my belief is higher than the
myopic cutoff uh you know then then I
always experiment because my optic is
the right thing to do and then on top of
that there's the information value if
I'm below the single agent cutoff I do
for an agent who doesn't have social
information
uh you know that that person wouldn't
even experiment if he didn't get social
information now when we're given social
information that's going to reduce its
incentives right so down here there's
certainly no experimentation you know in
between here it's going to depend on
it's going to depend on the rate of
social information it's a lot of social
information we're going to be up here
with little social information we're
going to be down there
so a rise in social learning to get more
information from others that raises my
raises my value that's just that's just
black world's the trivial direction of
Blackwell's theorem and it decreases the
incentives because it shows up and the
exponent here and uh so decrease the
incentives and therefore therefore the
experimentation right so the more others
experiment the greater the social
learning curve be the less I'm going to
experiment myself
way behind time
all right okay so I gotta skip this here
so I've shown you how the social
learning feeds into the optimal response
or feeds into a cutoff that's
characterized by a first order condition
and what's missing now is well how do
these individual experimentation choices
how do they aggregate into a into a
social learning curve
D A lot of times
all right equilibrium exists it's not we
don't know whether it's Unique or not
but it's not going to matter
all right so here's the click right
everybody is connected and we get a
unique equilibrium
right there's full crowding out that's
not in the literature
uh and uh so Capital Tau on a capital
called Tau bar here is the
it's a single agent experimentation if I
was doing this by myself this is how
much I would experiment and there's full
crowding out in the sense that all the
agents there
they're splitting this experimentation
equally among themselves
the fact that there is full crowding out
that's not in the literature that just
comes from the uh from the optimality
condition of the last person to
experiments last person is essentially
solving the single agent problem and
therefore they cannot be more
experimentation than a single agent
problem
what's novel here is uniqueness right so
in in standard you know public good
games on networks there's a gazillion of
a gazillion of equilibrium because you
know the effort is perfectly
substitutable and what's different here
is that we are sort of providing this
public good of information
dynamically and you know we care about
the future right when we're impatient
right and so if you're trying to cook up
an asymmetric equilibrium what's going
to bite you is that you know at the last
time in the last person's experimenting
everybody's indifferent but I told you
before that front loading is beneficial
right so if anybody doesn't experiment
until the very end uh he would be
indifferent about experimenting at the
very end and then you'd front load and
benefit from that so that unravels all
all asymmetric equilibrium
right so that of course is only a
starting point to click here so here's a
more interesting Network right the the
infinite line I think what is this large
finite Circle here
and uh let me just uh you know this is
just how the contagion spreads let me
solve this thing here right I'm going to
take the I'm going to take iris's
position here Iris observes John but
doesn't observe cutter right and so
after time Tau up until time tell
everybody experiments we know that in
equilibrium After Time Tau Iris thinks
well is John experimenting right and he
wouldn't be experimenting if he hadn't
seen any but succeed so the only way
that Jon would be experimenting is if
Qatar has succeeded so Iris has to think
about is Kata has Qatar succeeded
conditional on Me Myself and John not
having succeeded yet
Okay so we've got to solve this this
conditional probability here we're going
to stick this into Bayes rule
um and we find that it's it's this
expression here and the amazing thing is
this constant
as you might have thought that this
would be increasing over time because
you know there's Kata and Lily and all
the others in the in the chain there and
you know they're succeeding over time so
you might think that the that the
probability that John eventually sees
that would be increasing and that's true
right so there is a force that's saying
that social learning is going up but at
the same time iris is conditioning on
the fact that John has not succeeded yet
right because we're fixing the network
right and the fact that John has not
succeeded yet you know that's bad news
about uh anybody else having succeeded
and Dave's rule is telling us is exactly
these two effects exactly cancel and so
just like in my uh in my example there
the social learning curve is actually
constant right and so I can stick it now
back into the equilibrium condition from
before
and uh and that characterized my
equilibrium in the infinite line
unless they succeeded then you would
sort of everyone would very quickly like
not very quickly right when they would
eventually learn
okay well in this model in this in this
network
yeah but you know excellent small and
everybody every single person succeeding
is a very small probability and and yes
somebody will succeed but then it has to
sort of feed down the chain so it might
take a long time
as F1 goes to zero my the time at which
I observed success is going to go to
Infinity stochastically why does it take
time for that
John starts experimenting but he only
succeeds at uh at an exponential rate
all right so expectation is going to
take one period time one for John to
succeed and for this to feed to Iris
because only see the outcomes and the
outcomes are no I understand my proposal
was everyone experiments for Epsilon
periods and then stops then you have
infinitely many people have succeeded
and then
after the time when you stop in the CCA
success the information considers spread
instantly right but in this network yes
infinitely many people will succeed I
agree but the the typical person who's
going to succeed is going to be far away
from me because a very small percentage
of them succeed
all right
um let me think okay so my welfare and
my my
information measure information I'm just
going to measure by the by the aggregate
information that h i gets in the very
far future in order to come take the
minimum overall agents
just to make sure you're not cheating
and giving me Network one person learns
and others don't for the welfare I'm
going to take the same and that could be
infinite right so we've already seen a
network the infinite line the agents
learn perfectly in the in the long run
for welfare
um you know P0 times y That's the value
you would get if I just told you the the
state immediately right that's the best
thing you could ever get but that's
certainly an upper bound Devil's not
tight yet right because
um that's the that's the value if if you
learn perfectly immediately but the the
thing is not everybody can learn
perfectly immediately because if you did
you wouldn't experiment and if nobody
experiments there's no information from
others to learn from
right so somebody somebody has to be
doing the work here right so and there's
a there's an upper bound on the on the
value of an agent who's actually doing
an experimentation I skipped that step
for time reasons but it's this
expression here and it may be lower than
that right so that's also an upper bound
on
um uh on the value of experiment on the
on the value of the word stop agent here
right so we're going to call this here
our second best Benchmark and that's
justified by the fact that I'm going to
show in a moment that we can achieve it
right so there are networks where all
the agents are actually getting this
here okay so that's the that's a tight
upper bound
all right skip that
so how do the how do the examples fail
in the click uh you know learning is
very fast so this is the aggregate
learning curve capital B here so
initially we learn fantastically but you
know it stops right so there's too
little information the line is the
opposite right in the line we eventually
learn but it takes so long
right and so we're impatient right we
don't like the Epsilon saying that that
Krishna proposed terrible this is worse
than a click
um foreign
okay so finally with 10 minutes to go
here comes the real Network the angry
network uh the angry network is supposed
to look realistic and it's it's a
realization of the configuration model
right so the configuration model is my
favorite model of random networks works
as follows
agents have stops and then stops
randomly Connect into links
that's it
right so that that really is the
configure rate that's you know you know
in general you could sort of say people
have different degrees right here making
regular
I'm going to say a little bit about the
things that might go wrong right so two
of my steps could connect to each other
and then that's not really a link so I'm
going to scrap that off it could be that
I have two links to Ben but you know all
these things are pretty unlikely if the
network is large right and so the
configuration model Works nicely as as I
goes to Infinity the network is
symmetric enough that equilibrium is
unique so Tau I and v i here are my
unique equilibrium
experimentation times my equilibrium
values
right and so now what I want to do is
I'm going to characterize information
and Welfare as a function of network
density right so in any in any finite
Network I know what network density is
it's just ni the number of my stubs
which is approximately number of my
links
now as this goes to Infinity you could
say well you know just think about sort
of the configuration model where
everybody has 17 17 links right so that
would be 17 down here and take it up to
a billion or so and then at some point
to Infinity but we can go beyond right
because we could say that you know maybe
you're connected to one percent of the
agents out there
right and so then as we shoot the number
of agents to Infinity the number of my
my neighbors is not just infinite but
you know it's a percentage of the of the
population right so there's a spectrum
over here that's now way more than
infinite right and so in between a
relevant range and that shouldn't be too
surprising if you if you studied your
random networks it's the logarithmic
range where the number of neighbors is
proportional to the logarithm of the
agents out there right and so that's
this turns out to be the right measure
of network density this somewhat awkward
spectrum of the finite range the
logarithmic range and the in the
infinite range in that yeah the symbol n
is like degree
each and I would and I told them that's
a total degree and that's a total degree
and Lambda is uh a role is easier and a
row is
okay just look at this here yeah uh row
is the percentage of uh of people that
you're connected to
right and so this is just a complication
because you know with too many steps
then actually you will start wasting
steps on connecting twice to them
that's just the one minus E to the minus
it's just correct
is it really number of things
okay
okay so this is the right measure of
density as shown by the theorem here
that limits
information and limit welfare are indeed
a function of the of the limit density
as defined on the last slide right so
for any sequence of Networks
uh with with existing limits right where
both the
I will be converging one of the three
ranges here
um any subsequent of networks has the
same limit information the same limit
welfare
right and so the limit information is
decreasing it's not so surprising right
I mean if you're better connected you
learn faster and that drives out your
incentives to experiment yourself
I said what the theorem is telling you
is that there's a there's a threshold
and there's an algorithmic range at
which point uh the crowding out is going
to be so strong that in the aggregate as
a number of Agents grows to Infinity the
accurate information still stays bounded
right so below the threshold in
particular in the finite range here uh
the information is going to aggregate
just like in the in the infinite line so
the infinite line is down here where Nu
is equal to one
and if the network goes too dense it has
too much crowding out and eventually
that's gonna we know already right I
mean if we if we connect to everybody a
role has gone to Infinity here you know
then we're approaching the click and The
Clique we know we're not aggregating
information because there's four
crowding out I don't know so what the
red line is telling you here is that
there's a threshold in the logarithmic
range where where information where
asymptotic learning starts to fail
all right so that's the red curve the
blue curve is welfare
right and so welfare as I was saying in
the beginning uh for welfare density is
a two-sided sword and because on one
hand we we want to have density because
it accelerates the learning that's
important because we're impatient
right but at some point if the network
grows too dense we're already learning
super fast so at that point it really
becomes a question of how much
information do I learn right and so as
the network cross tensor total
information starts to decrease and then
the welfare also decreases here
and so we see that the the second best
welfare Benchmark V Star here is
achieved precisely in the
logarithmic range really I should be
saying in the range between uh finite
and proportional degrees right so second
best welfare is achieved if and only if
the degree explodes asymptotically in
the absolute degree explodes right so Nu
is equal to Infinity but the
proportional degree the proportion of
nodes that you're connected to if that
vanishes right that's necessary and
sufficient for for the second best
welfare benchmark
what a sigma star here
in this range where uh where the
Network's already pretty dense
um we're going to learn asymptotically
at the deterministic time
right there's going to be a time at
which all the social information is
going to hit me
all right so social information is BT
function you know it used to be a
function you know an infinite line it
was a constant function uh in this range
is going to become a it's going to
become a tsunami right so it's going to
hit me there's going to be this one time
when all the social information is going
to come crushing down uh on me and that
time is is Sigma and if uh that time
Sigma star is such that learning
perfectly the state at time Sigma star
if that social information makes me
indifferent about experimentation at the
at the initial time
at Time Zero uh well that defines uh
that defined Sigma Star right and so you
see that this is kind of the right
condition here right so if uh if if
initially I'd have strict incentives to
experiment you know and everybody would
do it and there would be a lot of
information it would hit me much earlier
uh if this was negative here so this was
less than C then initially nobody would
experiment and you know there wouldn't
be information coming around so that's
precisely the right uh the right time at
which uh at which sort of the
information
uh sort of this finite amount of Imagine
information that's going to come at some
future time is exactly going to make me
a different that time zero
all right I'm four minutes all right
okay so what else is there
including questions all right okay what
else is there
um these networks right so the random
networks they look very general and
realistic on the other hand in the in
the random networks every agent is the
same
it's kind of like macroeconomics right
it pretends to be very general but
really every person is the same right
and so in that sense this network here
even though it looks sort of much more
like an example in a way it's richer
because the the peripheral agents are
different from the core agents right and
so in in the generalizes the star and
you know what we can show is that the
the core agents they experiment less
they're better connected they have more
social information and therefore they do
less and they're better off right and so
then as we let the periphery grow large
we can do the exercise from the random
networks again we more or less get the
same result right so this is sort of the
density of these core periphery networks
where now we're measuring the
the core size which sort of density and
so we see that again the the red curve
is the information is decreasing in
connectedness whereas the welfare is the
welfare assumption
um
type of links
so uh I was talking about density of
links how does more links affect
information and Welfare so here the
question how does a type of Link affect
information or whatever right you could
say that Twitter is maybe a directed
Network LinkedIn might be an undirected
Network and other networks might be
clustered in the sense that my neighbors
are also friends amongst each others
right and so what we control here is
that sort of holding the degree fixed
the directed links are better than
undirected links and undirected links
are better than uh than clustered links
but the effect is not large
right so one more link
uh reverses the reverses to order right
so the under record five network is
better than the the record four Network
and the Triangular six Network where you
have three triangles that's better than
the than the undirected five Networks
foreign
absolutely right and so the
interpretation of that uh well that's
the type of Link matter you know
assembula klemper it it is you know the
degree is large it doesn't matter but
you know the degree is small it's uh you
know one more degree might be a big deal
right
so
um wrapping up uh I'm gonna have a
tractable model of experimentation on
Networks
the way we get that is by making the
learning as simple as possible right and
so that's what perfect good news does
and that allows us to sort of uh you
know get a characterization of best
responses in terms of cutoffs that then
allows us to characterize the learning
Curves in in all sorts of uh all sorts
of Networks
the hope is that we can put this into a
bunch of other models right and so
there's a there's a size of literature
out there about
so learning on networks that that really
is public goods on networks right where
you have this reduced form modeling of
networks where you know in the model
it's really just a public good
from your Crampton and um and galio to
go yell and so now here is a Bayesian
model of learning and networks where
learning is really sort of our our base
interpretation and you know you already
see differences right in in Galileo to
go yell the center does all the
experimentation the peripherals free
ride on it whereas here it's the
opposite way around right the center is
what they call a passive connector not
doing any experimentation themselves but
you know
brokering the information if you will
between the between the peripherals
right and so the hope is that this you
can sort of
more broadly use this model here to to
investigate sort of the specific
features of information and networks and
you know what's the same across public
goods and what's specific for
information
we have time for one question
you have questions
so uh thank you very much
foreign